all right this is on how to negotiate or
the art of deal-making whether you like
it or not you are a sales person you're
going to be persuading others to buy
into your ideas your services your
product your career path investing in
you in some capacity you need to learn
how to persuade so we'll talk about a
few different techniques that I use
routinely for negotiating which isn't
exactly the same as persuasion if you're
interested in the general broad scope of
persuasion and influence I highly
recommend you pick up the book influence
by Robert Cal Dini or chal Dini I'm not
sure how it is pronounced but that is a
classic that I read many many times in
the very beginning my career had found
very very helpful getting into
negotiating a few things to keep in mind
mantra number one is he or she who cares
the least wins
so having options is very helpful for
giving you that type of confidence
walkaway power the other is doing an
exercise called fear settings so that
the downsides of losing the negotiation
are d tooth in a way and you can find
out more about fear setting at tim dot
blog for slash ted I did an entire TED
talk on this so I won't spend time on it
right now a few things when it comes to
negotiating a price a deal structuring
etc the first is that you want the
counterparty the person that you're
negotiating with to negotiate against
themselves first how do you do that if
possible I like to ask them to make the
first offer put something on the table
to get the ball rolling or to initiate
the conversation and very often you'll
be interacting with someone who you can
position is the expert you know more
about this than I do you've done this a
hundred times this is my first rodeo why
don't you just put something on the
table so that we can discuss it as a
starting point that is in my experience
very often more beneficial than it is
harmful sometimes they will try to
anchor that is give you a very very high
ball price or a very very low ball price
depending on if they're on the sell side
or the buy side
but generally speaking I like to get the
other side to open up and show their
initial hand at that point you can do
what's called a flinch and when I lived
in China and
in 96 I saw this all the time where he'd
go to buy a shirt or a phone charger
whatever it might be and you would offer
a price and then the woman selling it
would go and make all these faces and
contortions and so on she did that very
deliberately to get me to then back off
or retract or a back step right you
don't have to make some type of extreme
theatrics to accomplish this you could
just pause hmm you know that's that's a
bit more than I would have expected and
then wait and the waiting is the hardest
so if you can develop the ability to sit
in silence you will have a tremendous
advantage in negotiating so you want to
flinch in some fashion first wow that's
a lot higher than I would have expected
then perhaps they backpedal which
happens a lot especially with novice or
intermediate negotiators and then you
can very simply ask is that the best
that you can do do you think this is the
best that you guys can offer and again
pause and wait when you want to get into
some of them more I suppose
sophisticated or developed techniques in
negotiating different types of
bracketing how to make certain
concessions how to drill into what they
want the needs behind their requests so
they want a certain price but what are
the incentives are they trying to hit a
quota do they want to for instance be
remembered in some fashion or retain
branding maybe a statue in front of the
shopping center would do instead of them
getting top dollar on the shopping
center you're trying to buy something
like that there are resources that can
help with these types of more advanced
techniques one would be roger dawson
secrets of power negotiating I listen to
that in audio format it is available in
audio I don't know the quality these
days but I listened to that driving to
and from work during my commute in
2000-2001 and if I remember correctly
Roger made his first fortune in real
estate and I found it very very helpful
and particularly in audio so I could
hear inflection how he delivered certain
phrases asked certain questions the
other book is getting past no and the
author or at least co-authors William
ury you are why getting past no was a
follow-up to getting to yes
which was a book co-authored by the
founders of the Harvard negotiation
project I believe it is one of which is
William ury but getting past no is I
think the more pragmatic realistic way
to phrase many of your experiences in
the world of negotiating you're going to
be either trying to sell something that
isn't immediately obvious to someone or
you're going to be trying to buy
something at a price or with a structure
that isn't immediately obviously
appealing to someone otherwise it's not
negotiating you simply put something on
the table and you sell it or you buy it
the other facet of negotiating is
avoiding it altogether and that sort of
leads to this which is you can structure
your life to avoid certain types of
negotiation in the case of say my
podcast and podcast sponsorship of a
very lean team of just a few people and
we want to avoid altogether the extreme
back and forth that can be involved with
ad purchasing or selling this is very
routine and podcasts size of mind very
often F staff of twenty thirty people
and agencies and all sorts of folks
involved to avoid that we decided that
we would have everyone prepay there are
no payment terms no net thirty or
anything like that
we did not offer any discounts still
don't offer any discounts we would
charge a premium the way you get a
discount is by locking in today's
pricing because with the rate of growth
we expected with the podcast the
absolute pricing would always go up not
the CPM and so there are ways you can
set policies and systems in place in the
beginning so that you do not have to
expend many many cycles of negotiating
to pull that off though in the case save
the podcast you have to deliver a very
very high amounts of traffic with high
conversion all right so that in a sense
forces you to deliver a higher-quality
product and I always find that the
premium space or selling to the affluent
if you want to take a look at that book
to be much much easier than negotiating
with players who are looking for the
lowest cost option so those are a few
approaches to deal making and
negotiating and structuring different
approaches to putting together say
packages for buying or selling that I
found useful and I hope
do as well
you